speaker pelosi joins us right now madam
speaker good morning to you good morning
let's start with that shot yesterday
because it was something it was historic
to see
you and vice president harris side by
side it was one of the
times i thought i wish she had her mask
off because i could tell you were
smiling
behind that matching mask how did it
feel up there and what were you thinking
because you've been in that seat many
times but not like this
well it was exciting of course it was
exciting when i was the first speaker
and
president bush acknowledged that but
this was more than
double uh it had a synergy too it was
something very
very special but what made it even more
important we're there sending a message
sky's the limit for girls and women
that's important but what was important
is that the president's speech
reflected that importance it was a
speech that was a triumph
for women for women in the workplace for
women at home
violence against women he talked about
he talked about equal pay for equal work
he talked about
family and medical leave he talked about
building back better
for our country and to do so we had to
have the fuller participation
of women that that was throughout his
speech so i think it was a triumph for
women for families for children for all
americans
he also talked about though madam
speaker the big huge price tag it's like
that phrase go big or go home
you guys are certainly going very big
and the republicans are saying you're
going too big
and they're making it clear they're not
on board how are you going to find a
compromise when the
the republican side is already saying we
are not going for this
well the republicans all vote no and
take the joe
they don't mind going home and bragging
about some of the initiatives
that were in our rescue package and
that's what they usually do
they don't mind giving a nearly two
trillion dollar
tax break of a cost to our national
debt they give a two trillion dollar
gift to the richest people in america 83
percent of the benefits
of their tax scam in 2017 going to
83 83 of it going to the top 1
so what we're talking about here are
investments nothing brings more money
to the treasury than the investment in
education that we make
early childhood and the president has
universal pre-k
early child to k-12 higher education
that he talked about
lifetime learning for our workers all a
part
of the plan that he is putting forth all
of that brings more money than anything
back to the treasury so these are
investments and they
all of a sudden their deficit hawks when
they were giving away money to the
wealthiest people in our country
under president trump yeah i i hear what
you're saying
i i get the point you're making i love
politico this morning said
though it's like trying to put a
rhinoceros through a garden hose
last time i check it's difficult to do
and very painful chris christie said
it's like giving a teenager a credit
card with unlimited spending
so that's cute that's cute but it isn't
even it isn't true
but it's what they would say but what we
have to say is
we have to go forward building back
better
uh there's nothing more expensive than
not
investing in our infrastructure are you
prepared to do it without the
compromise madam speaker are you
prepared to do it
well we've never we've always had comp
compromise
on infrastructure now that has been the
least
partisan initiative we can take over the
years
all of a sudden now of course they're
saying well infrastructure
is not work workforce development it is
if we want more women minorities if we
want more
of our veterans and everyone else
involved in these
the constructions that the president was
talking about we have to have
workforce development so again we'll
have to
make the case we always we have a
responsibility to reach out in a
bipartisan way
to find our common ground and i think we
will on many of the
items and we just have to the american
people know
that we need to involve women and
protect children
children learning parents earning that's
that's what we have to be thinking of so
how are we going to have
more women and dads actually moms and
dads
in the workplace when they have
responsibility for the care of their
children
so it's it's pretty exciting it's about
community
and community has the word unity in it
president's present speech was very
unifying
in the country if not in the congress
we'll see
racial justice is very much on people's
minds during these times this is very
difficult
president biden called on congress to
pass the george floyd justice and
policing act
by next month which would be the one
year anniversary of the murder of george
floyd
do you think that that's a realistic
deadline can that be done
yes i think so i'm very proud of karen
bass who
has authored the bill in the house now
working in a bipartisan way in the house
and in the senate with senator tim scott
and others in the senate she has
she's optimistic and even the senator
said in his response last night
that he was willing to be working in a
bipartisan way
we have to get this done millions of
people across the world
and constantly in our own country came
forth
after last may when we saw the murder
of george floyd to and said something
had to be done
justice and policing act came forth the
family asked it to be named for george
floyd they asked me that madam speaker
will you name it for
our brother i said only if it is worthy
of his name
and the legislation to date has been
worthy of his name
your speaker certainly right now but
let's talk about the census numbers that
have just come in that do not look good
for the democrats
there is a possibility that you may not
be speaker
uh let's not worry about that that's
okay year and a half away and i feel
you're not worried about it but you're
not no i think the democrat
well you know what elections are always
uh
a contest and you see what happens in
them but i feel very confident that the
democrats
will hold the majority after the next
election i think that what for all the
huffing and puffing the republicans are
doing
these numbers were not as good for them
as they had hoped they wanted three in
texas two in florida and rest
but many of the much of the growth in
many of these places that picked up
more numbers more more members in
congress were
the growth was from uh hispanics
african-americans and the rest so we'll
see where those votes go
but this is right now the best politics
of all
is to get the job done for the american
people
the the blueprint that was put forth by
the president last night
to meet the needs of the american people
that's what we're about we're not
worrying about
uh who's going to be speaker you're
right year and a half is a long time i i
take your point
speaker pelosi thank you so much if
everything goes according to plan we
won't be wearing masks much longer
and you wear some of the best you're
trying to figure out who doesn't
yeah i see you thank you very much i
hear you're going to be a grandmother
yes
congratulations madam speaker i know we
got to go but what do your grandchildren
call you i'm looking for
i know we got to go guys what is that
they call me mimi and
i have nine but i can just say this for
sure
knowing you admiring you when you have
that grandbaby
you will have everything i know right
now i'm walking around holding packs of
rice bouncing right
i can't wait to hold a real baby thank
you thank you madam speaker nothing more
thrilling
thank you so much my pleasure to be with
you thanks a lot